it looks like I'm in the middle of
nowhere and I guess I am about a mile
that way is Kanak on the west coast of
Greenland about 700 miles north of the
Arctic Circle the town has more sled
dogs than people
the locals some of them still hunt seals
novel when the ice retreats in the
summer and just outside the town someone
is listening for nuclear explosions in
1989 183 countries signed the
comprehensive nuclear-test-ban treaty
the Cold War had just ended and with the
threat of nuclear apocalypse seeming
just a little less likely the idea of
the treaty was to completely ban nuclear
explosions even for research two decades
later and the treaty is still not
enforced because politics but the people
who drafted the treaty thought that
might happen and created the preparatory
commission whose job it is to get
everything in place for when the treaty
hopefully eventually comes into force
and even if it never actually happens to
try and do some good anyway and this
over here is one of the results is 18 an
infrasound listening station part of a
network that spans the planet it's a
microphone barograph
a set of very precise air pressure
sensors and it listens for very low
frequency sound waves far beyond the
range of human hearing they're less like
sound more like massive disturbances in
the air that travel around the globe
after enormous explosions an electronic
engineer and made you up here now is to
maintain the infrasound station if you
just put a micro barometer in the air
the noise from the wind will be killing
every signal so we have these arrays we
have 96 inlets they call goes to the
barometer because we have that many
inlets it is not really probable that
their wind noise will be exactly the
same at all these inlets so they are fit
to a central manifold and the wind will
sort of cancel out it really does
detecting something doesn't mean there's
been a nuclear test it might be a
Meteor breaking up volcano erupting or
even a massive iceberg carving up a
glacier nearby but if it can't be
explained like that then governments
should start asking questions results
from here go to the Commission's
headquarters in Vienna via a base in the
middle of town where they're combined
with those from the dozens of other
listening stations around the planet as
well as that the Commission uses
hydroacoustic sensors to detect
underwater explosions seismic stations
that detect earthquakes from nuclear
tests and radio nuclide detection
stations that check the level of
radioactivity in the air you can see
from the time difference when the
individual stations detects the pressure
wave from that you can deduct what
direction it's coming from the nuclear
test ban treaty if it ever actually
comes into force will apply around the
world even up here in the Arctic and
theoretically some rogue government
could be ridiculous enough to try and
get away with a nuclear test in the
Arctic afterall back in the 20th century
about a fifth of all Soviet nuclear
tests were in the Russian Arctic and
that included Tsar Bomba
the largest nuclear bomb in history even
if new testing in the Arctic is unlikely
data from here can still help
triangulate other explosions when you're
designing a network to keep watch on the
planet not just where most of the people
live that network really does have to be
global even if that means setting up a
research base in one of the most remote
locations I'm here because of Chris
Hadfield generator Arctic it's an
amazing chance to be here on the top of
the world Ellsberg and Glacia right
behind us and we're gonna put on a show
on trial Massey Hall November 12 and
apart from that go see all the videos
from all the people who are on this
expedition links are on screen and the
description now thank you so much my
pleasure nice to be here